Mitch McConnell Mitch McConnell has been
heckled with chance to retire it's
because he had some kind of a medical
incident it seems where he froze up
during a press conference had to be
escorted away from the lectern I was
back on the trail and and hecklers are
chanting that he's too old and he's got
to retire
[Applause]
[Music]
Elaine and I are really excited to be
back at Fancy Farm
on behalf of the strongest Republican
team we've ever run in our state
yeah
for those of you who keep count this is
my 28th Fancy Farm
about 28 fancy Farms
I want to thank Father vendors and
Stephen Elder
for finding a way to keep Conti Farm
going even with pork prices going
through the roots
thanks to the Kentucky State Police
rough it's rough for McConnell he is a
total Pro politician and so he works
through it just fine whatever that
Health scare was doesn't seem to have
really slowed him down all that much
it's still pretty good on his feet as
far as politicians go
people are are calling on him to retire
I'm of two minds on this
on the one hand
the guy's pretty good at wielding power
I know I don't know in his heart of
hearts is he really a true conservative
I don't know I do know that he got rovie
Ray overruled and the guy deserves as
much credit As Trump does on that point
because he held that seat open amid a
lot of political pressure he held that
seat on the Supreme Court open until the
elections one of the reasons Trump got
elected one of the big reasons Trump got
elected and then they got a good judge
confirmed they got a number of good
judges confirmed they ever ruled rovy
Wade so I think the guy deserves a lot
of credit it is his lasting Legacy he
said it's his lasting Legacy so I like
him I have a lot of affection for Mitch
McConnell for that reason for that
reason alone that would be enough
now
I know he's a little old and and
I was just in Hungary the Hungarian
government is relatively quite young and
they're getting a lot of great stuff
done so maybe that would be good to have
energetic young conservatives out out
there in the United States advancing the
the next stage of the conservative
vision and not stuck in the old
platitudes of the past okay yeah
I guess here's my counter though to that
point
do we have any evidence that Mitch
McConnell's replacement is going to be
any better than he is do we have any
evidence of that whatsoever do we have
any evidence that the guy who's going to
replace McConnell is more conservative
more energetic better Adept at wielding
power I don't see any evidence of that
the guys who might replace Mitch
McConnell
are John barrasso John thune or John
cornyn the John caucus is looking really
strong at replacing Mitch McConnell as
the Republican leader in the Senate and
I like these guys personally they're
very nice guys I have nothing against
them whatsoever I'm not saying they
would be so much worse than Mitch
McConnell but I don't
I don't see any evidence that they would
be so much more conservative so much
more energetic and effective I just
don't see it
which is why I can't get on the whole
deposed McConnell train
that's why I can't get on the deposed
Putin train all the really excitable
liberals the interventionists who want
to just go bomb every country on Earth
they said we need to depose Vladimir
Putin we need regime change in Moscow
to which I say oh yeah
for what
for what who's going to replace Putin
none of them know none of them have an
answer to that
some of them sometimes say Alexia
navalny because it's the one other
politician name they've ever heard of in
Russia he's the leader of the opposition
who spent some time in America now he's
in prison it's not going to be navalny
guys the guy's in prison okay
by the way what do you know about Alexi
navalny nothing nobody knows anything
about these guys
but it won't be him anyway it'll be
potentially a much more dangerous
adversary a much less prudent uh wise
adversary than Putin I'm not saying
Putin's a great guy
but
if you're if you're telling me that he's
so bad that we need to bring the force
of the United States to depose the
leader of a nuclear reform or superpower
can you at least tell me who the
alternative is
who's going to come next no of course
not which is how we get into these
bungled foreign policy messes that lead
us into quagmires for decades and
decades
what's the same kind of thinking going
on here
show me who's going to replace McConnell
who's going to be the the right wing far
more conservative far more effective
leader I just don't see it right now go
to hallow.com it is clear that the libs
are giving up their morals in any Common
Sense there's no better time to build a
daily habit of prayer and meditation
building a habit of prayer can help you
cultivate an attitude of gratitude
focusing on what you are thankful for
can increase positive emotions and
improve overall well-being hallow is the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
United States it's helped many maintain
a daily prayer routine and it can help
you too download the app for free at
hallow.com Knowles you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start check
out father Mike schmitz's Bible in a
year available on the Hello app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes with hallow you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions using Halo
to connect with others who share your
beliefs and values can provide sense of
belonging support and Foster a sense of
community also you have an obligation to
your God to pray regularly don't forget
that helps you but you have an
obligation okay so make sure you go
check it out right now hello go to
hello.com Knowles get an exclusive three
months free that's three months
absolutely free at hallow.com Knowles
Trump doesn't want to debate of course
he doesn't want to debate he's 30 points
up in the race and he realizes that a
debate entails a lot of risk because all
these candidates are going to be taking
shots at him
and not much upside so he's going to
increase his lead what from 30 to 33
points that's not a lot of upside but
there is a lot of risk if he has one of
these bumbling moments you know a Marco
Rubio glitching out kind of moment or
Rick Perry he forgets the third point in
the series or I don't know any any of
these moments they happen during all
sorts of debates
Mondale during Reagan got absolutely
destroyed by one debate
Trump says okay I don't want to I don't
want to debate the problem for him is
his base wants him to they're all saying
is he going to go into the debate and I
say I don't know if you're leading by 50
and 60 and 70 points do you do that or
not I don't know should I okay you ready
Paul we take a free poll
should I do the debate
well maybe we'll do something else you
know see some people say yes but they
hate to say it because it doesn't make
sense to do it if you're leading by so
much but they like it for entertainment
value because they're selfish
they're selfish okay so he he misjudged
that one he usually has his finger on
the pulse of a crowd really well that
one he misjudged and he misjudged it he
thought he had them he because he did a
little test right he goes does it make
sense for someone who's up by a
bazillion points to debate no so he's
thinking oh good okay so now I can prove
that my audience doesn't want me to
debate and say okay good let's do a poll
should I debate
make it this is the uh Caprice of crowds
yes we do want you to debate and he's
there and he goes shoot oh man he
doesn't he doesn't break his smile the
guy knows Show Business show must go on
because I shoot ah darn I didn't see
that one coming okay he goes no but
and I think quite rightly he says you
only want me to debate because you'll
find it entertaining right and what they
say yes that's exactly why we want you
to debate he goes yeah okay that's very
selfish you know and he's kind of joking
about it a little bit but it does expose
a real weakness in the campaign right
now
which is everybody knows that Trump
doesn't really stand to gain very much
from debating
and everyone wants him to debate
including his most fervent supporters
if I were advising Trump right now if I
were on the campaign I'd say don't
debate at least not the first one see
how it shakes out
but
if I were in that crowd at that rally
you know I would have been there yeah
you definitely should debate it's going
to be awesome you're going to make Jeb
high five you or whatever you're gonna
make fun of Rand Paul's face I don't
know you're gonna do those things that
are so mean and nasty and entertaining
you're going to talk about Rosie
O'Donnell what was it you say the only
woman you've ever insulted is Rosie
O'Donnell
it's going to be funny but there's not a
lot to
it's not a lot to be gained from it so
he kind of saved it there at the end or
maybe we'll do something else okay you
guys are selfish come on get out of here
you come on stop it but a bit of a bit
of a misstep or a
miscalculation and he's gonna have to
play it very carefully because the other
the other field the rest of the field is
going to call him a coward
and he's got to make sure the that if if
the people pulling in single digits call
him a coward
doesn't matter but if his own audience
if he doesn't give his audience what
they want
that's a much bigger problem boy what a
great clip that was now um
[Applause]
ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time